[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCES ANGULO: First
things first, I'm Frances.
I'm the lead program manager for
Chromebook adoption at Google.
And so today, we're going to
talk all things Chromebook.
And I'm joined by Russ White,
who we'll talk about Grab
and Go today.
If you've been using
the Dory app, great.
If you haven't used it
yet, give it a download.
That's how we'll take
questions for this session.
So go and get that
started, post them there.
We have a whole panel of people
here to answer your questions
about Chromebook deployments.
So please go ahead
and get that queued
up so that you can put all
your burning questions there.
What we're going to talk about
today is, why Chromebooks?
I think most of you are
here because you know.
But I'm just going to make
sure we're aligned on that.
We'll talk about driving
adoption in your organization.
I'm going to tell you
all the secrets and how
we did it at Google.
And then, of course,
Russ is going
to talk about Grab and Go.
So the first thing I want
to do is just share with you
that Google actually is solving
a lot of the same problems
that most of our IT
customers are solving.
We're a mixed-fleet ecosystem
of Mac, Windows, Linux,
and Chromebook devices.
We have a huge Chromebook fleet.
As you can imagine, we're one
of Chrome Enterprise's largest
customers.
And we also care about
improving operational efficiency
and reducing IT spent.
And so that's one of the reasons
in a long list of reasons
why we love Chromebooks.
So from a user
standpoint, Chromebooks
offer a distraction-free
productivity environment
that's purpose-built
for Cloud workflows.
And obviously, from a
business standpoint,
they're security
built-in by design,
an intelligent investment,
both in management and cost.
And so because of that
whole slew of reasons,
Chromebooks are a great
choice for our organization
and hopefully, yours.
And so with all of that in mind,
Google set out with this goal
that users are
happy and productive
on Chromebook devices.
And that's a very
specifically worded goal.
We could have set a goal that
said, users use Chromebooks.
And that just means we give
Chromebooks to everybody.
But we have this
secondary achievement
of making sure that people are
happy, and can do their jobs,
and can do them well, and
are excited about being
on the platform.
And so if you share those goals,
then this session, I think,
is going to be particularly
interesting for you.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to walk you through what we call
this adoption timeline, which
is from start to finish,
from evaluating Chromebooks
as a potential device to
put into your fleet, all
the way to getting users up
and running on that device,
and how to handle
changes, including
attrition from the platform.
And what you'll
see at the end is,
we're going to
provide some artifacts
for each stage of this
journey so that wherever
you are in this timeline,
we've offered something that
will help you either in the
challenges of that phase
or maybe even move on
further down the timeline
than you're in now.
So from the onset,
you're probably
going to be evaluating
what types of hardware
are sufficient or acceptable
for your environment.
And one of the
questions that we get
asked, actually, quite
a lot is, how do you
decide what platforms to
bring in to the Google space?
What makes Chromebooks great?
How do you determine what are
the qualities of a trusted
platform?
And what are the
ways that you look
at security and management?
And so there's an artifact,
if you haven't seen it,
that we've recently published
that talks about exactly
what Google expects from a
platform when they bring it
into the fleet, including
prevention in terms of risk
of infiltration into the
platform, risk detection,
the ability to
manage the device,
how much control we have over
what kind of data it consumes.
All of those features are
listed in this document.
And again, at the end,
I'm going to give you
this list of artifacts
that you can reference.
But when we evaluate
all of our platforms,
those are the things
that we consider.
And Chrome certainly passes the
test, especially with the way
that the security is
designed in the platform.
And so if you're on board
with bringing Chromebooks
into your environment, the
second most common question
we get is, which Chromebooks
should we bring in?
There is, of course,
Google-made hardware.
And we're really excited about
it, and we think it's great.
But we're also including Google
support third-party vendor
hardware.
So there's a lot of
different choices.
And when you're
looking at what's
the best device to bring in,
of course, the first things
that you're going to think
about are performance and specs,
and what types of work
that people are doing.
But when we surveyed Googlers
as they're bringing Chromebooks
into the ecosystem
of choice, the things
that were most important
to them-- and these
are in order-- are they
wanted a lightweight device.
So our workforce is
generally quite mobile.
A lot of people move
between offices.
They do quite a
lot of traveling.
We exist in cities where there's
a lot of heavy commuting.
And so people are carrying
their laptops a lot.
And so weight was one of
the biggest requirements.
The Pixelbook is the
lightest device in the fleet
that we offer.
And so it was obviously
very satisfactory
to the users who adopted it.
They also want high-quality
hardware look and feel.
People who are
doing important work
want to feel like the hardware
that they have supports
that important work,
especially when you
have a choice between other
premium hardware options.
They want a device that's
supported by their peers.
There is this phenomenon.
If you choose a Chromebook, and
you're really excited about it,
and you enter a team where no
one else is using that device,
that it can cause people to take
a second look at their decision
and really question if
that was a good choice.
And so having peers understand
what the device is capable of
and making sure that it's
pervasive across roles
is really important.
They want a great
battery life, of course.
And a touch screen was actually
close to the top four reasons
that we got from Googlers.
And so achieving
all of these things
was actually quite simple
for us with Pixelbook
because it is
high-performance, it
is a high-quality
piece of hardware.
It has a touch screen, it
can work in tablet mode,
and it's the lightest
device in the fleet.
And so because of that, the
employees that we survey,
90% of them are quite
satisfied and want to keep
and would recommend their
Pixelbook to another team
member.
And so once you've selected
the kind of devices
that you're going to
bring in your environment,
now the next question
is more strategic.
Are we going to mandate,
from a business standpoint,
that users will now
adopt Chromebooks
that's our new fleet?
Or is there going to be
an ecosystem of choice
where people can
choose, and you need
to influence their behavior?
And so at Google,
we actually do have
both scenarios and different
teams for different reasons.
And so each of those
different approaches
requires different strategic
ways of executing on them.
Managing change
and telling people
that their platform
preference is not
going to be part of the story
when they select their device
requires things like
making sure that you're
choosing the right
people to start with
and expanding your scope
to better candidates.
And if you saw our
presentation last year--
and it's up on the channel,
and you can reference it if you
didn't--
we talked a lot
about segmentation
and how we think about
segmenting user types
and identifying good
candidates for Chrome OS
before we push
the device in mass
to people who might
not be prepared for it.
And what you'll learn
later in this presentation
is that the percentage of
people who don't have experience
with Chrome OS is actually
a lot higher than even
we anticipated within Google.
And so that means that if you're
going to push this change,
it requires a lot of care.
And if you're working
in an ecosystem
where people have a choice,
that's a different story.
And so that's where we do a
lot of marketing initiatives.
What we've found is
that getting the device
in the hands of the users is
one of the most effective ways
to get them excited
about the device.
And so Russ is
going to talk later
about Grab and Go, which is
one of the key initiatives
that help users get
experience with Chrome OS
before they make the plunge
or are exposed to the change.
And so I call this
out because if you're
going to deploy
Chromebooks, you have
to consider which of
these, if not both,
are going to be true for
you and then consider
that either change management
or a lot of education
and marketing is going
to be required depending
on what you do.
Obviously, from a
provisioning standpoint,
we're really excited that
Chrome is so easy to provision.
So in the case of
a Chromebook, it's
really a matter of enterprise
enrolling the device
and delivering it to the desk.
Because of the nature
of the way that we image
alternative platforms
like Mac and Windows,
we save 109 minutes
every time a Chromebook
is deployed in place of one
of those other platforms.
And so from a management
and operation standpoint,
the more Chromebook
we deploy, we
have this sort of
exponential gain.
And that's just
based on the nature
of images for those other
platforms within our ecosystem.
And so you've provisioned
the device, which is great.
And you've delivered
it to the users desk.
And this is where we
actually learned quite a lot.
And this whole
presentation is designed
to try to prevent
you from having
to learn all of
the things that we
spent a long time figuring out.
And so what we first tried
to do was just respect
that people were
new to the platform
and then give them as much
information as possible
for them to be successful.
And the way that we
determine success
at this point, which is getting
up and running, and keeping
the Chromebook as
your primary device,
is, do they stay
on the platform?
And so if we're experiencing
attrition from the platform,
that means we're
doing something wrong.
And so what we learned is
there's three basic phases
that users are going
through when they're
adopting this new platform.
The first and foremost
thing on their mind,
especially with new
hires, is, I just
want to get email, calendar, and
the essential work apps set up.
That's the first
thing on their mind.
So when we talk about
sophisticated, cool pro tips,
and productivity hacks,
and workflow examples,
it's way too much.
It actually underlines
that they're
about to experience
a learning curve.
And so we don't present that
mountain on the first day
that somebody gets a Chromebook.
We sort of ease them into
the basic critical things
that they need.
The second phase after
the first few days
and once you get into
that first or second week
is personalization.
So people tend to
download personal apps.
They're starting to
translate their workflows
from other platforms.
And so that's basic information
of tips and tricks--
I used to do this on Windows.
How do I do it on Chrome?
Or I'm more familiar
with Mac, kind
of curated information
that will help people
ease into the transition is what
we present at that time frame.
And then once you get a few
weeks further down the line,
that's when we get
into the productivity
hacks-- here's how you use
hotkeys and keyboard shortcuts,
and those types of things.
And so this is an
important lesson for us
because 84% of the Googlers
that were assigned a Chromebook
device this year had little
to zero use of the platform.
And that's a lot.
That's self-reported when
we survey the new people who
were assigned this year.
And so that really
taught us a lot
about the type of information
that we need to provide
and how we need
to break it down.
And so again, the artifacts that
we use and the strategy will
be given to you guys at the
end of this presentation,
including tips and
tricks campaigns,
and the type of content we
have there, and also service.
So we do survey all
new users of Chrome OS,
and we ask them about
their initial impressions
so that we can give direction
for additional resources
that they need.
But another important part of
running Chromebook adoption
is staying on top of
a monitoring goal.
So if you set a target
for Chromebook adoption,
or you're just trying to
understand the basic health
when you introduce this
in the environment,
there's a massive monitoring
and dashboard need.
And we've spent
so many iterations
designing charts
and figuring out
what questions to ask--
should this be a part chart?
Should this be overlaid
on something else?
And so we've done
all of that work
and provided a template
example for you
on what a dashboard could look
like if you're trying to answer
some of these questions.
Because these are the five
things that we generally
wanted to answer.
How many people
have a Chromebook
versus how many
people are using it
as their actual daily driver?
So there is a circumstance where
an employee could potentially
have more than one device.
And we treat that
circumstance differently.
So if they have a Chromebook
and also another platform,
that's not the same
definition of success
as if a Chromebook is their
only operating system.
And so that's question
number one for us
in terms of defining adoption.
We also want to know why
people leave Chrome OS.
And you could just
ask them, and you'll
get this massive
flow of open text
that you have to
later interpret.
We've also done that for you.
So we've given you
a list of reasons
that you can use to aggregate
and collect that data.
How many people are choosing
a laptop at the time
that they have a
hardware decision?
So any milestone
where people could
select an alternative
platform, whether it's
moving to a new role
or refreshing a device,
we want to know what
the trends are there.
New hire assignment
is absolutely critical
because it sets the tone for
what the future will look
like in terms of
growth if you're
trying to create a new
population of users
versus focusing on converting
the current population.
And then lastly, where
does Chrome assignment
stand against some of
the other platforms?
So our goal is that
Chrome assignments
are above the other platforms
and, obviously, in the up
and to the right line.
So we've created some
examples on those questions
and how we track
and monitor them
so that you can
potentially take that back.
And so I mentioned that
we survey new users.
But we also surveyed this
super important and very
well-respected group
at Google, which are
people who leave the platform.
And so they tell one of the
most important data parts
of the story.
What we've found is that
you could ask a user, hey,
if we gave you a Chromebook,
would you be able to use it?
And you'll get a lot of
anecdotal and hypothetical
reasons why they
could or could not.
But actually asking
someone to try it
and figuring out when they leave
the platform in their journey
why they're leaving produces the
most valuable insights for us.
And so what we learned is
that 30% of the people who
left the platform
left for reasons
that we could in theory control,
and so reason categories like
education, resources,
training, materials,
communication about what the
platform is and what it does.
And so because of that,
that attrition data
both tells us how to set the
direction to maintain retention
but also gives us the
most actionable feedback
for product teams.
And we'll talk a little
bit about that right now.
So our goal is, obviously, that
people can use the platform
as much as possible.
But we also have
this responsibility
to communicate this story
of, if people can't use it
or don't want to,
let's figure out why
and make Chrome competitive
against the other platforms.
And so we encourage all of
our customers to do the same.
Filing a Chrome bug is step
one to collecting feedback.
And Google does this as well.
And then stack ranking and
prioritizing your requests
is the next phase.
And so we presented a
template for you in our kit
that you'll get at
the end of the day.
And these might seem
like obvious questions.
But this helps
narrow exactly what's
required for you to both collect
and monitor your own story.
But it also creates an artifact
that your technical account
manager or customer
success manager
can help navigate and
escalate where necessary.
And so this is driven by that
attrition feedback and also
the new user feedback.
Creating those surveys
in a way that's
easy to monitor, and measure,
and present up on a dashboard
can be hard.
It requires a lot
of data aggregation.
And we dedicated a huge amount
of UX research resources
to this so that we can present
these artifacts in a way
that we think are intelligent
and are actually valid research
methods.
So you'll get those too.
And so just to summarize where
we sit in terms of Chromebook
at Google, every time we
deploy a Chromebook based
on the devices that
we're purchasing,
we save 50% just
in device costs.
Every time we
deploy a Chromebook
over another platform,
which I mentioned
before, we save 109 minutes.
And for every single Chrome
OS support interaction,
there are three from
another platform at Google.
And so that means those other
platforms are generating
three times as much support.
And there's a lot
of reasons for that,
and we could talk about them.
But obviously, they have
to do with complexity
of the platform, and the
way that the images work,
and a number of other things
that users can experience just
based on what the
platform is capable of.
And we do have approaching
90,000 active Chrome devices
at Google.
And I mentioned before that 90%
of our users who have Pixelbook
are satisfied with the devices
and would recommend them
to their employees.
And so based on this timeline
and all of the things
that we've accomplished, we
see this as great success.
We tripled our adoption
population since last year
with adoption being defined
as users using the platform
as their primary device.
And so this URL is available.
You guys can also get access
to this after the session.
But what this URL points
to is the timeline
that we spoke about and all of
the artifacts that are related
to each of those milestones.
So that includes surveys,
tips and tricks campaigns,
the dashboard template example,
and any other resources
that we felt could
be beneficial to you
wherever you are in the stage
of your adoption journey.
So definitely take
a snapshot of that
so you can download
it and have a look.
And so I mentioned before
that one of the best ways
to get users excited
about the platform
is to get the device in
the hands of the user.
And Grab and Go has been one
of our most successful ways
to do that.
So Russ is here to
talk about that.
RUSS WHITE: Great.
Thanks, Frances.
I'm Russ.
I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about Grab and Go,
our self-service
Chromebook loaner
program that we run at Google.
We're going to talk a little
bit about why we created it,
why we're still working on
it, how it works, what it is,
and then talk a little bit
about some of the successes
that we've seen at Google,
and, perhaps, how you can
make some of those your own.
We have some really
great options
for how you might be able
to deploy your own Grab
and Go program.
So first up, let's
talk about why.
Google is just like
any other company.
We lose a lot of
time to IT downtime.
Our devices break just
like everyone else's.
And when we first
started this program,
we were focused on
minimizing that downtime.
So IHS Markit estimates that
North American businesses
lose over $700 billion a
year just to IT downtime.
And we also knew that the
traditional loaner program
journey really isn't
great for anybody.
So our users had to
come to help desk
when the help desk was open.
They had to wait in line.
They had to get a
loaner device that
probably wasn't a great device.
And they had to do that again
when they were returning it.
For IT staff, they were
maintaining those devices,
ordering them,
provisioning them.
And they also had to spend
all the time handing them out.
And none of that is really
fun work for our team.
So we had a lot of
signals telling us,
go in this direction.
We also had a couple
of opportunities
that we knew about--
the fact that Google
employees use our help desks
at least once per year on
average, and oftentimes,
quite a bit more than that.
And we also knew that around
80% or 85% of Googlers
could be fully
productive on Chrome OS.
Not all of them required
a Windows or a Mac OS
to be productive.
So we knew that we could
put a device in their hands
that they could get
their work done on.
And then why we're continuing
to work on this program?
We're still iterating on it,
we're still making it better.
Around 35% of Googlers used the
Grab and Go program in 2018.
Around half of them--
18%-- were using the
program to work around
a true productivity blocking
problem, so some IT problem.
Maybe their device was
broken, or forgotten,
or something like that.
And then the other
half, another 18% or so,
were using the program for
more convenience reasons,
maybe be picking up a
device between meetings,
or maybe they're
traveling and just want
to pick up a laptop when they
arrive, something like that.
So at its simplest,
this is Grab and Go.
You walk up to one
of our shelves.
They are just out there.
You can use it
whenever you'd like.
You walk up, pick up a device,
sign it in with your Google
account, and get back to work.
When you're done, you
bring it back, plug it in,
and that's it.
There's no IT team
intervention required.
You don't have to
talk to anybody.
You just walk up
and take a laptop.
So the core components
of the program
start with the physical domain.
So the devices are
a key part of this.
We make sure that our devices
that we put in our program
are Enterprise grade.
We want Googlers
to be productive
when they're using the devices.
We want them to be durable.
They need to survive going
from person to person,
being thrown back on the shelf,
being thrown in your bag.
And we also want it
to be cost-conscious.
We don't want to spend so
much money that we're really
giving everyone two devices.
We want it to be, perhaps, a
little bit cheaper than that.
So that's the first piece.
The second is the
shelves that we buy.
So we prefer to
have shelves that
are modular because we have
offices of different sizes.
Sometimes we need
a little tiny one,
sometimes we need
a very big one.
In all of these cases, we
want charging to be built-in.
That's a key part
of the experience.
You need to be able to pick up
a device and walk away with it,
and know that it's
fully charged.
So that needs to be an
obvious feature of the shelf.
And we also want them to
have key safety features.
And that's something that
we didn't think about a lot
early on, but we
really do a lot now.
We want them to be
resistant to tipping.
We want them to be grounded.
We want them to be coated
with a non-conductive material
so that you can remove that
from your line of thinking.
And the last piece is, we've
designed our signs and stickers
to be very self-explanatory.
We found that the loaner
flow that we designed
was a little bit
awkward for some users.
It felt like you were walking
up and stealing a laptop
if it wasn't explained at all.
So the signs that
we put up there
are very clear, very concise.
They are stepped signs.
It's actually very similar to
what you saw in the last sign
saying, no, just really pick it
up, sign it, and bring it back
when you're done.
And we also placed
instructions at key points
in the user journey.
So when you open
the laptop, there
are stickers inside the laptop
that explain how to sign it,
how to connect to Wi-Fi, how
to return it, things like that.
Another key ingredient of our
program is Chrome OS itself.
Chrome OS makes it very easy
to just sign it and get back
to work.
So things like Chrome Sync or
the integrations with G Suite
products make it
incredibly easy to get back
to work once you've signed in.
These devices are
very, very secure
because of the built-in
features of Chrome OS.
Things like verified
boot, automatic updates,
signing restriction, those are
all super easy to configure.
We'll talk a little
bit more about that
in the next couple of slides.
And these devices are very,
very easy to maintain.
We manage our entire fleet just
with the click of a few buttons
and the Admin API,
the admin panel.
So we have a very easy
time managing a fleet
of upwards of 2000 devices.
So it's not all just signs,
and devices, and Chrome OS.
There is, actually, quite a
large management infrastructure
that we've built. At
the center of all of it
is an App Engine
application that's kind
of the brain of the program.
That application is where
program administrators monitor
the performance of
the program, who's
assigned to what, which
shelves might be low on stock,
those kinds of things.
And it also is streaming all
of that data and information
to BigQuery.
Another key piece of it
is Google's Admin API.
That's where we enforce
a lot of those policies
like verified boot.
One other key policy
that we enforce
there is, a custom-built
Chrome application
is pushed to every single
Grab and Go device.
So when the user signs in,
the first thing they see
is that application popping up
and greeting them and saying,
hey, welcome to Grab and Go.
Here's how you use this device.
That application
also guides them
through setting
your return dates.
They can ask
questions there, they
can report problems,
those kinds of things.
And then, of course,
all of these things
allow for integration with
the other internal tools.
So we have a ticketing system,
we have an inventory management
system, those kinds of things.
So like I said, when we
first deployed Grab and Go,
we were doing so to avoid
lost productivity situations,
so forgotten, broken laptops.
But after we deployed
it, we've found
that Googlers were using
this program for things
that we didn't really expect.
And we're still not
exactly sure how
to measure the benefit
of those things.
So some of those
things are travel.
So we've found that
a lot of Googlers
will actually leave
their laptop at home,
travel to another office, pick
up a laptop there, use that,
put it back on the
shelf, and then travel
back home just to avoid
carrying a laptop with them.
We also have big groups of
shift workers inside of Google.
We recently published a blog on
how Waymo is using Grab and Go.
So they have shift workers
testing driverless cars.
And they take a Grab
and Go device with them
every time they go out.
So there's a couple of
shifts of those workers.
And they've saved
money on not needing
to buy devices for all of them.
And they also have a really
great management solution
with Grab and Go.
And then, of course,
like Frances was saying,
it's a really great way to get
Chromebooks in people's hands.
Using the device is
a really great way
to break down barriers
and understand the power
and ease of use of Chrome OS.
So we're very happy
with Grab and Go Google.
We've found that each
loan really only needs
to save about 25 minutes
of productivity time
to pay for itself.
And our most conservative
estimates show that in 2018, we
saved around $17
million, if you convert
productivity time to dollars.
So this is definitely
something we're
going to continue investing in.
And it's something that, like
I said, we're very happy with.
If you're thinking about
deploying your own Grab and Go
program, but you're seeing
all of these pieces that
need to be put in
place and thinking,
I will not do that,
I have good news.
We have really great partners
that can work with you.
So we've spent the
last year or so
working with some of
Google's closest partners.
The list is much longer
than just what you see here.
Their services range anywhere
from procuring the hardware,
setting up the devices,
customizing the application
that we built, doing
inventory management,
training of your team on how to
run the program, anything up to
and including even
white glove service.
If you're more of a DIYer
and you're thinking,
this looks great, I can
do that, that's excellent.
We have code all
open-sourced on GitHub--
github.com/google/loaner.
Everything's there from code
to art, to deployment plans,
to whatever-- everything you'd
need to deploy your own Grab
and Go program.
And like I said, the partners
talk to your partner.
Definitely start a
conversation there
or feel free to
engage with the ones
that we showed on
the last slide.
Well, thank you, everyone, for
coming and thank you again.
Have a great day.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]